y
[Música]
a
y
nueve meses después del golpe de estado
en mi armar el gobierno militar ha sido
acusado de graves violaciones de los
derechos humanos durante la represión de
las manifestaciones para archivar y
documentar estos abusos un grupo de
investigadores en línea tanto en mi al
mar como en el extranjero han comenzado
a trabajar en un proyecto llamado
myanmar witness un proyecto en el que
son verificadas las imágenes que son
tomadas por los ciudadanos el director
de este proyecto es venda main street' y
nos explica cómo los investigadores
verifican estas imágenes utilizando
herramientas que son de libre acceso en
internet
cada vez que recibimos fotos y vídeos
los recopilamos los pasamos por una
especie de lavadora para comprobar la
información information
una de las investigaciones bastante
importantes que realizamos fue para los
donde hubo un atentado a principios de
abril muchas personas murieron y hubo
rumores en internet de que se había
utilizado armas pesadas
por ejemplo cosas como esta que es un
proyectil de lanzar cohetes o una bala
altamente explosiva de un arma de fuego
hemos recopilado muchas imágenes desde
el primero de febrero y una de las
imágenes que recogimos abajo fue ésta
esta imagen era bastante interesante
porque tenía características específicas
que coincidían con la foto donde se ve
el cohete
basándonos en estas dos imágenes podemos
ir a google sirvió para recorrer la
calle e identificar donde tuvo lugar la
escena
pues sant en westerns
podemos encontrar este mismo techo este
y también este
así que podemos demostrar que la foto
fue tomada en esta calle de lago donde
los militares estaban atacando a los
manifestantes mientras éstos huyen de la
zona
[Aplausos]
y documentamos los acontecimientos
graves se trata de ataques militares
contra civiles y tenemos que tomarlo muy
en serio decimos confíen en lo que
publicamos porque exponemos estos hechos
de manera que puedan ser verificados de
forma independiente
el aspecto más importante del proyecto
es que es una plataforma educativa así
que está conducido principalmente por
birmanas
aportamos diferentes niveles de
experiencia en especialistas
internacionales
pero también tenemos un gran equipo de
investigadores y hermanos
un equipo de 15 investigadores a tiempo
completo ha realizado ya unas 50
verificaciones para mianmar witness 8 de
estos investigadores son birmanos y por
lo tanto se enfrentan a diferentes
riesgos al compartir lo que ocurre en su
país de origen conversamos con una
investigadora que hace parte de este
equipo ella habló de forma anónima por
razones de seguridad
hay civiles de a pie que trabajan o
viven allá y que documentan y nos envían
lo que ocurre en la zona han detenido
periodistas
así que si después de este golpe el
papel de los periodistas ciudadanos es
muy importante siguen enviando este tipo
de información y documentación útil no
sólo a nosotros sino también a varias
redes y a los principales medios de
comunicación
puede haber otros problemas de
privacidad o seguridad si publican esos
vídeos o fotos en sus propias redes
sociales
puede ser muy arriesgado no sólo para
ellos sino también para sus familias y
allegados la inteligencia militar puede
hacer cualquier cosa pueden encontrarte
también pueden vigilar los hogares de
nuestras familias y el usuario de
facebook puede ser detenido por publicar
este tipo de información
hay violaciones de los derechos humanos
pero la comunidad internacional solo veo
una parte superficial de lo que ocurre
en birmania
estas culturas se llama el pilar de la
vergüenza y es una obra del artista
danés jens culture y está dedicada a las
víctimas de las represiones de las
protestas de la plaza de tiananmen en
beijing hechos ocurridos el 4 de junio
de 1989 el pasado mes de octubre la
universidad de hong kong solicitó que la
obra fuera retirada de sus instalaciones
donde ha estado expuesta por 24 años
para los activistas prodemocracia esta
decisión es una afrenta más contra la
libertad de expresión
nuestro observador forma parte de un
colectivo que sensibiliza sobre la
situación en hong kong a través del arte
ya han archivado el pilar de la
vergüenza en 3-d a partir de cientos de
fotos por su seguridad prefirió
conversar con nosotros en total
anonimato
fain cuando nos enteramos de la noticia
decidimos escanear la obra de arte con
una técnica llamada fotogrametría esta
técnica recrea un terreno o un objeto a
partir de las fotos que se tomen cuantas
más fotos haya más completo será el
resultado final
se pueden hacer fotos panorámicas
alrededor del objeto y tomás de trones y
el software se encargará del resto puede
intentar censurar el espacio público en
hong kong pero no pueden censurar
internet no pueden enviar hombres
armados policías o lo que sea a internet
una vez que está ahí está ahí para
siempre el hecho de que el pilar de la
vergüenza esté en hong kong no es sólo
cuestión de memoria es un signo de la
libertad de expresión que tenemos así
que quitarlo es un síntoma de lo que
está pasando en la ciudad
cada día tenemos menos libertad y están
reprimiendo todo aquello con lo que no
están de acuerdo
solíamos hacer arte público en la calle
al aire libre casi como un flash mundo
desde la implementación de la ley de
seguridad global no hemos podido hacer
nada y creo que las cosas sólo
empeorarán
caguas
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si usted
quiere comunicarse con la producción del
programa para compartir con nosotros sus
historias sus fotos y sus vídeos los
contactos aparecen en sus pantallas
nosotros nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces